rubis tu viens de vivre un gros bad buzz
après avoir voulu revendre lot de tomber
comment tu as une idée j'appelle répète
à un bête vers ben ça alors un baise
peut-être alors dit moi pour te fait le
buzz vient à moi je ne cherche pas le
buzz je suis juste une business woman
alors faut savoir que j'ai mis en vente
donc cet article qui est l'eau de mon de
ben d'accord donc l'eau vendue à 1500
euros kwh à 1500 euros
loto tombe à l'eau de montbard 1512 ya
des gens qui achètent attendait c'est la
connaissez la finale
mais quoi c'est à dire tune baignent
dans l'eau et après tu prends de greek
et eu l'annoncé le bain de minuit en
fait moi jeune adepte des bains j'adore
prendre débat enfin je trouve ça juste
incroyable de prendre des bains je vois
que ça rit mais bon moi j'aime beaucoup
prendre des bains et donc du coup j'ai
décidé d'en faire profiter à tout le
monde alors je vais faire une version
mini une version miniature donc qui sera
rendu à
750 bonne
mais chez ricoh témoigne de
tout est super bonne idée de cadeau non
du coup on est sur du 30 mai sa faune
succombent à travers 99 d'accord
t'as vu chez moi après je suis interne à
la
brebis alors ça fait ça ça fait
énormément parler notamment jeu
j
[Applaudissements]
non mais
castany super fou
géraldine n'a pas aimé le toit cette
idée moi qui me fait rire moi l'idée m'a
vraiment fait ressentir à travers
l'écran vraiment ça fait un super bon
c'est une odeur sucrée je me lave je
suis une fille super prof je me lavais
jugea bon mot je porte et je me lève et
tu sais d'où je viens barbie pour les
filles qui nous suivent franchement
c'est l'odeur très sucré ça ça ressemble
un peu à du victoria secret's maintenant
façon trop
nadine pleurs après tout se vend et tout
s'achète apparaît bien plus bas éthique
et ouais en fait je trouve que c'est une
sorte de du buzz un peu un peu voilà
bizarre mais chaleur dépassant du bazar
en effet business en question de l'eau
d'heure non
non non mais du business moi je trouve
que c'est très bien de vouloir gagner sa
vie et 1500 gaulle l'eau du bain
j'aimerais que nature et après tout dans
le contemporain ont fait des plugs d un
plug and à l'onf et le batteur nakamura
jean château
avait donné plein d'idées elle va vendre
son club en est la
prochaine étape en fait c'est votre pipi
du matin
du tout du tout du tout je crois que sa
part alors il ne s'est pas la démarche
n'a pas aimé l'idée de rubis banon mois
geipel j'ai pas trop aimé son idée parce
que l'image qu'il renvoie auprès des
jeunes générations c'est quand même une
image très controversée elle est suivie
par énormément de jeunes ruby
[Rires]
championne tant que ça reste que vous en
voyez vraiment pas
maintenant et à perdre
si ça ne tirait pas notre serait fait
mais tout ne va pas bien trop mal c'est
une ligne à kim hôtel du nord jim
d'entacher t'as vu ça mille cinq cent
vingt personnes
[Applaudissements]
l'accroché mahelma min escomptons bande
a atteint 36 ans vient de voir cela
crochet
[Rires]
ça m'a fallu enlever sa
5éme et demi comme de guinée
vente
croisée passe et 2005 à troyes mais oui
c'est une bonne surface lors de mon bon
ami 500 euros c'est 1 litre servant pour
les labels
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
10e fois un container mais
alors quoi justement parce que de passer
par serment en fin de vie c'était une
blague après je comprends que j'allais
faire des ventes à toi là vraiment il ya
eu des bandes mobiles
tu comprends la polémique ou pas du tout
où
j'ai compris en juillet n'ont pas trouvé
avec en france on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de ce genre de produits de
commerce je sais que wayne mais je sais
que ailleurs ça se fait ouais où ça où
est
[Applaudissements]
donc la cordillère des andes
en soit c'est sûr c'est pour cela pour
vraiment faire profiter alors en faire
profiter à m aujourd'hui tôt une
nouvelle idée tu vends tes culottes
salle voilà bien
non non non c'est pas des culottes celle
ses culottes que j'ai portée mais je
suis pour le psg d'accord ne s'est pas
tu les a portés combien de fois
quelques heures quelques heures
seulement donc tu es tu verras tu les
vents elle ponctue la rencontre
s'emballe la culotte oui sans bâtiment
v8
[Applaudissements]
et
la vérité mademoiselle airways
robbie est ce que tu as déjà vendu des
culottes last assassins
[Applaudissements]
on attend s'ils achètent il faut bien
qu'ils
génèrent
à
je suis prêt à rechercher une fille
preuve ses propres
excitez pas l'os ou la culotte dominique
montois cccd dominique ce qui domine et
qui s'est fait ces lots de bobigny
dominique je ne sais pas bonsoir c'est
celle au de ruby nient kaffrine stub
vous entendez ça je guillaume je vous ai
vraiment combien de jours on est livré
sur la commande
ça peut prêter à sourire mais je pense
que j'ai envie
que ça peut renvoyer un message qui
effectivement est dangereux pour les
jeunes filles
je vous explique le message et les
simples c'est qu'aujourd'hui plus vous
publiez de contenus à caractère sexuel
c'était un caractère sexuel
masculin j'ai vu à vendre du pain à
manger dans l'autre monde
j'ai vu la vidéo vous dit j'adore me
faire plaisir dans mon bain acheter le
lot de moitié aucun moment j'ai décidé
de l'érotisme
lui on publie ce genre de contenu plus
on génère de l'intérêt d'ondés l'argent
facile et face à cet argent facile il ya
des filles
bien des filles qui arrivent appris à
poser les limites et d'autres qui
n'arrivent pas à poser de limites dans
sa question c'est est-ce que vous avez
des limites là vous vendez l'eau de
votre bain à 1500 euros si un jour il ya
un homme qui me dit par exemple quelles
sont vos limites si on vous dit pour 3
mais je me faire l'amour avec toi là
également
montré ce qu'on entend jouer messi
pression je peux vous laisser la
répandre et ses rubis comment d'autres
ailleurs monde et vous vous me dit ça
mais vous vous rendez compte nommées ca3
que vous dites
pratique chez moi mais j'ai pas du tout
dit ça il a dit non mais écoutez bien
des risées
5000 euros
vous aimez
par s'énerver
[Applaudissements]
la mine par mine tout le temps laissé la
balle et g20 bien kelowna n'est pas tout
le temps nominé à vie parce qu'elle veut
ça la livebox
qu'user mois prochain vous êtes tous les
jours dans l'émission j'irai bien qu'on
l'entende et guillon mais je mets un
jour qu'elle ait pas écouté il est alors
intéressant ce qu'ils font
mais bon voit tous les jours c'est bon
on la voit on n'a pas tous les jours
avec nous via les cds sur 1
rubis nikara
constitution ya un moment donné je ne
vends pas mon corps je vends un article
c'est un produit qui a été confectionnée
c'est là c'est quoi la pensée quand
c'est vous verrez ces gens
je m'amuse dans mon bain avec des
canards je me fait du bien dans le monde
il est où le problème elle me traite de
prostituée
mais là c'est chiant gilbert des dates
du tout mais rugby rugby moi je vous
trouve très sympathique mais vous vous
foutez de notre gueule quoi
[Rires]
en étalant mais c'est artistique de
vente de lots dégueulasse à 1500 euros
et des culottes porte des sandales
quelques heures les sentiments ruby
c'est pas possible reprenez-vous là vous
êtes en train de vous pervertir vous
avez du talent vous êtes quelqu'un de
bien et là c'est débile ce que vous
faites c'est stupide vous rendez compte
l'exemple que vous donnez et c'est quoi
le fait que voulait pas
à la fête c'est parti elle était
exactement valais et la liste alors la
règle quand vous connaissez pas
quelqu'un voilà mon nom mais comme vous
venez dans l'émission allez voir tiens
tiens robbie est très drôle elle
est très drôle sur les réseaux mais
c'est parce que je vous aime que je suis
déçu de vous lire je n'ai rien et c'est
même pas qui c'est
mais ce n'est pas une mais bien sûr
ça m'a ya rien d morales qu'elle veut se
dire oui au projet que le porter et des
lots du baas à 50 balles tu es petite
fille qui la regarde et qui
avant que c'est que
c'est vrai
à la scala à la carrière
et des abrutis pondérée pour acheter
battre un tel appareil à des mineurs qui
sont
les paquets les packs lcc l'aude mon
ego
en train d'utiliser une voix soit sur ce
sont des gens de télé super bon c'est
une bonne idée de cadeau mais b culotte
c'est pour aller plus loin pour aller
plus loin car tu es beau lot de mamba
euh non l'eau de bain de rubis carafe un
show c'est hyper intéressant comme
elle n'a pas comme ça la saison
la bella de minutes
non non comme un artiste je peux les
parties dans ok dolphin en fait il ya
des influences beauté des influences et
les influences voilà bien-être ou humour
mais en fait vous salue humour aussi
vous c'est quoi votre projet non mais
vraiment elle a plein de risques
alors que j'ai presque envie d'aller
regarder c'est ce qu'elle fait sur un
stade oui et moi j'aimerais me touré
fais quoi moi j'ai le matin même
j'aimerais qu'elle me réponde cinq fois
plus qui fait quoi mais à bientôt est ce
que tu as déjà vu ces vidéos oui elles
et ordonnez donner l'exemple
notamment celle des ben justement où
elle dit qu'elle s'amuse l'otan a vu
d'autres mais j'ai vu où l europe à
laquelle
tout a rien vu du tout allez merci
je te connais tu aimerais juste qu'elle
me réponde par rapport au devis des
émules et votre question quel est votre
projet mais son projet était gérée par m
excuse pas répondent les voiles pour
répondre non non
il n'y a pas de projet d'ailleurs c'est
un peu
la raison vas-y sur les ponts ou quel
est le but que qu'est ce que tu vas
faire un break c'est qu'elles ont
congédié question
projet elle est tombée mais qu'est ce
que tu souhaites faire dans la vie qu'on
est mal parti ouais ça ça avait pu 0
charte abattre et après on va t'amuser
nombreux dans ma peut-être shibata
assumer prend un peu de cette rappeuse
en concurrence beach c'est quoi ça
baby sitter
j'ai deux siècles
et c'est parfait
[Applaudissements]
jma des émissions politiques
baba mais là j'en ai connaît la suite à
cela
la tâche
[Applaudissements]
mais jeudi
ruby non il nous reste dix secondes à
dire ma chérie restez pas là
c'est tout simplement que celle aquiline
c'est une reine femme d'affaires
caucheteux rappeuse bien et je
revendique aussi la liberté de la femme
au temps que femme japon aussi j'assure
de la femme s'en est passé mais on y est
on y reviendra rugby c'est comme un
sourd comme ça
dans mon lit mineur qui regarde
mais je vous laisse y voilà ça arrive je
suis fait ça va tu vas
tu sais très bien elle a dépêché mais je
sais pas elle est fan dimanche soir
c'est pas la peur de moi cette beach
avait connu déjà la classe énorme menace
des leads mrc